stiamo andando a fare una trash di
regali con gianluigi lui deve fare
recano alla ragazza fanno i loro regali
da ussi perché sta per fare un bel
regalo dice possiamo dirlo ho pensato
bene di farle un mac e scuse lei che ti
regala loro si fanno sempre sti regali
da ricchi
c'è così ha narrato dal giornale vi fece
le eleggono 8
io invece la sorpresa lp mila luigi il
secondo anno che facciamo a casa nostra
il segreto a sieve estratti tra tutti le
cugini i fratelli in o il nome di un
pugno c'è un sorteggio si tra i cugini e
i fratelli perché ognuno dovrà fare
prete un regalo a uno dei parenti in
maniera segreta
il secondo anno di fila che mi capita
enrico ma che ho fatto di male
delirio prenatale
eli roth eni iri hotel ieri gianluigi ha
comprato il computer
voglio morire due morire sì anche perché
non avrei una casa natale
[Musica]
in tutto questo ho trovato però il
regalo da fare enrico che un bel regalo
una bella pensata un bel rasoio che
portano in giro qua faccia e dicono
ricobelli non posso fare qualcosa
mascherati da halloween e che ti piaccia
enrico che ti piaccia perché ti piace un
rasoio ti piace io voglio sperare il
secondo anno di fila che mi capita
enrico il secondo anno di fila ma c'è
giustizia nel mondo no non credo
io ho quello gli ho regalato il computer
che ci piaci diurne che piacevo fatti sì
io avrei dovuto regalargli un foglietto
con ho già dato
a guidare ma non vuole entrare ultimo
blog mas blog ma numero 24 e siccome lo
starete vedendo il 25 vi faccio anche
tanti auguri di natale sono un gene
ritardo perché devo andare a prendere il
roba da cucina di questa sera da notare
qui la bellezza di questi calamari qui
che cosa sappiamo che cos'è questo nome
travaglio che stava maturando abba che
stanno cenando al canto abbiamo ne frego
allora perché io devo fare il trancio di
salmone vedo fare a tartare di questo ma
enorme qualcosa di più enorme che cosa
boccone di tonno ma che sta scherzando
ma sto donne gigante che c'è qua altro
abbacchio e qui che c'è maggiore di
quanto abbacchio c'è è sotto 10 kg qui
abbiamo le ostriche l'abominio della
natura e poi abbiamo dei gamberi vabbè
io devo fare una spesa non trovo nulla
certo la farina la farina e la prima
cosa di sbagliato solo quella torta ho
capito adesso bisogna solamente
scaricare tutta questa spesa mannaggia a
me quando ho proposto di cucinare nei
ragazzini me ma io e vedrete tutta
questa roba che è stata facilmente
predisposte all'interno del mio frigo
beh non è stato facile iniziamo quindi
ad affettare un chilo tipo e mezzo e un
quarto di come si chiama questo
guanciale il costa cipolla che svampa
m'ammazza m'ammazza parentesi
divertentissima la scena al supermercato
vado metto tutta la roba sul sul rullo e
la tizia rifà da questo non ti serve le
marmette via roma dai co questo è questo
che ci fa e non c'è abbastanza può dire
signori e sono tornato a casa con la
spesa che ha deciso la tizia e non so se
c'è tutto perché vedo che gli dicevo no
state sì ma avrei dovuto avere uno che
bella questa inquadratura con quella
albero
parentesi che sta perdendo i regali
eccone ii 1 commesso giusto un pochino
di guanciale e pezzo decò dica così per
insaporire questa bottiglia di vino
l'avevo presa per sfumare amatriciana mi
sa che me la schouler o per superare la
giornata è andata così
da notare come sto attento alle quantità
oddio un vuoto di roba ce n'è un'altra
li vediamo quante ce ne entrano 4 5 6 9
10 11
12 13 c
15 ci ha ripensato nel gioco altre 16 17
che porta sfiga 18 buonanotte cucinati
addio delicious
sono venuto apposta non mi fido
assolutamente di lui è il mondo ha in
mano il natale la riuscita del natale
dipende da te lo so mi fido mi fido
assolutamente da questo capiremo se è un
bel ad oggi tutto convinto ci penso io
lì dentro ragazzi che mi ha rivolto il
mio compito
gabriele rispetto bisogna spinare
fiscale e fare tutto quanto
perché davvero riprovare io a sapere che
la fai tu
anzi potrebbe fare dal pescivendolo la
prego mi aiuti cose a caso questo è il
momento di vita lo sai come si troviamo
dall'altro lato sofia soffia c tipo
l'angolino quello che sta a cardano
cerchiamo su internet 7 pesce mai corte
dice regioni o togliere la parte della
pancia mangia factor
ok al contrario ma tiene con in discesa
con indice con l'indice che ho compiuto
questo cresce scusami
forse c'è una speranza non solo delle
ben 7 ma per cosa da che schifo è quello
c acquisti dentro o magari come li tolgo
è che aveva subito male la ricetta ma
polpette di carne disco
veramente no maria io mi rimane solo la
tartara che adesso però che natale di me
e mi stavo per sistemare gli occhiali
per farmi capire la politica non si può
mangiare cosa natale faccio assaggiare
un'altra idea cabria nel l'odio il
grande idea willwoosh si ritrova così
scorsa d'arancia tirata a caso
assaggiare un secondo allora
praticamente a forza di test che cos'è
finocchio questo spero che ti attacchino
del commenti o bici testa number two
com'era c'è tanto finocchio adesso però
maggiore molte di meno
c'è stata davvero non saprei arancione
il finocchietto fine secondo me questa
potrebbe essere la strada un pizzico di
sale
la tartare di salmone con l'altro le
cose io il coraggio ragazzi e ragazze
stanno a casa non voglio morire perché
chi lo sai che ho fatto fino adesso ha
fatto capire non puoi abbandonare tuo
fratello 20 con un attimo in bagno ma
chi sempre complotti perché non sono
belli perché sono spontanei
le mie vene mi sta tenendo qui con
l'inganno no grazie che parlando di
amore si sanno fare qualsiasi cosa vuol
dire che gli altri come che tu sai che
noia
no forse se fosse certo voi ci siete
andando bene con tutto anni con coraggio
e con che con il regalo di arrivo cioè
di colpo in sé di serie di comparse
sanno per cosa posso dirti che credo di
aver individuato il regalo di enrico ma
adesso l'ha individuato non nel fare
mente locale
no ho cercato lì sono andato prima li ma
la tua mente locale non ti ha mandato
eccolo sì a tutti i quesiti un ok dopo
il rasoio
prima ha detto che era giallo ma a me
sembra più verde allora in camere capito
al volo
ho deciso di usare una tecnica diversa
l'anno scorso incartato tutto bene
invece quest'anno di riccardo ma li
muove non farli pensare esso meglio come
qualcuno con delle doti mano ad
ulteriori nella nostra famiglia potrebbe
capire sono io prendo questo e spinga
spinga fino a cacchio
potrebbe essere stato qualcun altro
adesso spilla i punti di spillatrice
automaticamente su un'altra ok questo
potrebbe essere la scritta di qualcun
altro
ho scritto con la destra cercando tipo
di avere un'altra calligrafia così male
noi avrà fatto tipo gianmarco capito un
regalo così pronto per andare a farmi
insultare da tutti quanti
mamma mia ragazzi qua abbiamo già fatto
il porcaio mi sono dimenticato di
riprendere l'antipasto
fatto sta che c'erano che riprendiamo tu
che mostri le foto brava si è un po
appannato perché fa caldo i vostri che
vai
[Musica]
poi mamma mi vedete le mie due per tar e
questo è un pancake cos'è un pancake con
formaggio spalmabile e salmone salutato
si sono poi chiedere che i capelli
bellissimi ai blog ma siete meravigliose
salutiamo sentiamo buona vittoria
no no no non siamo un po brilli e la
sacra madre brilla la vaccara madre qui
abbiamo giulia che sta facendo una
cosche cose sono dei fusilloni fusilloni
con crema di cipolle che stai fidando
adesso poi c'è il tonno scusate per la
botta che ho dato qua e infine la
bottarga mammamia gianluigi mese to
abbiamo una calamarata pacchero con
calamari da trino e gambe perfetto team
con pochi fatto malissimo ancora in
tutto questo
l'istinto le nostre madri c'è mia zia
fiera che si è resa conto della video
della videocamera che si sta facendo
bella con le orecchiette ragazza sia
medita con il cappello su cappello da
babbo natale e mia madre con le orecchie
da da playboy le ali d'angelo e un
ventaglio di più potete vederli sul
tavolo col quale sta facendo impazzire
culto c'è un delirio c'è un delirio veri
idioti loro che stanno magna basta il
magliano
che tenero questo rapporto che supera
che ci dici ma che ci fai qui dentro
tesoruccio caruccio di cosa poi non e
capelli ai quindi quello di capire
[Applauso]
questo cappello origina prezzi sotto
palazzo cappelli e qui iniziano i giorni
dopo che mi ero sotto l'albero
enrico mario maria mario giammarco
marcone per me
[Musica]
[Applauso]
anche mino è un calibro è parsa pietra
sei tu però sempre come prende questa
saga
ragazzi scarpa carta giocatore
[Applauso]
è una matrioska di scatole il mio pacco
si è comprato ieri prego bisogna dirlo
no non si devono oscurare i budget
[Musica]
allora ovviamente così non si capisce
devo dire che è geniale
io non voglio più forte legali ti piaci
di biagi urla da barba
ci piace un regalo un match decisivo
sono stanco di solito sono tornato a
casa
sono le quattro meno 10 sto morendo li
so non so nemmeno cosa sto inquadrando è
arrivato il momento di fare una cosa che
vedono settimana che sto aspettando deve
fare che aprire gli uffici che regalo di
luigi dopo strati e strati e strati e
strati camel e vediamo del mare cavato
uno stop
[Musica]
di dottor martens e stima netto gli
avevo detto che dovremmo un sacco di dio
sono molto contento molto molto aperto
e a questo punto era il momento di
salutarci con questo punto mentre al
blog masche finito
volevo ringraziarvi per avermi seguito e
perché abbiamo creato un meraviglioso
per rapporto quotidiano vorrei dire
qualcosa una frase a effetto ma non mi
viene e ho capito che la cosa bella di
di questo format è la spontaneità e il
non iscriversi nulla e non pensare a
niente
prima di premere lecco che secondo me è
anche una cosa positiva specialmente per
me che sempre attento a cosa dico a cosa
non dico come lo dico come non lo dico e
toppo il più delle volte banalmente ho
fatto ogni giorno un qualcosa di
particolare e non è mai capitato di
cercare di trasformare ogni giorno in un
giorno importante ed è forse
l'insegnamento che che mi porto a casa e
che spero di poter replicare in 2019
senza anche bisogno di riprenderlo ed è
anche l'invito che faccio bui della
augurio che faccio poi cerca di
trasformare ogni giorno in un qualcosa
di importante cerca di darvi lo spazio e
soprattutto cercate di darvi
l'importanza che merita grazie a voi
quest'anno è stato speciale himara
strano riprendere ancora mi farà molto
molto strano però che dire io vi auguro
un buon natale ma soprattutto di lavoro
un anno speciale per voi è l'unica cosa
vi separa dal da renderlo speciale
sessualmente voi quindi impegnatevi
sappiate che tutto quello che vi capita
capita per un motivo e la maggior parte
della serie capitano capitano lo penso
io la penso così capitano perché noi
facciamo immobili attirarle in un certo
senso è poi non voglio generalizzare
quindi fate in modo di attirare
solamente cose vi facciano bene anche se
fanno male possono far bene è arrivata
una mail auguri di natale perfetto la
chiudiamo così ragazzi non ci vediamo
domani alle 14 ma sicuramente questo
termine 19 fare in modo di trasformare
in un anno importante
o almeno lo spero e che dire io vi mando
un bacio grandissimo e il blog ma 2018
finisce qui ciao
buon natale c'è già un po